Of all the polarizing issues in politics todays,
and of course, there are many, the climate
debate is at the top of the list.
Climate change seems to be one of the 'you're
either with us, or you're against us' topics,
usually debated by people immediately taking
a partisan stance rather than a well thought
out position.
This past year, I lost a good friend who told
me that she could no longer be associated
with people who will even debate climate change,
and I'm someone who has had such conversations
on this very show.
I think the most hate I ever got was when
I had Alex Epstein, author of The Moral Case
for Fossil fuels in for a sit down.
Alex's argument isn't against man made climate
change, instead he's more focused on how to
increase human prosperity with what we have
right now.
Essentially, his argument is although climate
change could be real, fossil fuels still have
many net benefits for our society.
After endless tweets, emails and messages
from angry people, Alex did a follow up video
himself where he answered around a 100 viewer
questions.
Engaging with people who have different views
is what the battle of ideas is all about.
On the flip side of the debate, I've also
sat down with Michael Mann, a climatologist
and the author of the famous 'The Hockey Stick
and the Climate Wars', who is a thought leader
in the climate change debate.
I've discussed climate change to some degree
with believers in man made climate change
like Sam Harris, Michael Shermer, Richard
Dawkins as well as some with a more skeptical
view such as Andrew Klavan, Stephen Crowder
and Ben Shapiro.
And for the record not one of these guests
believe the exact same thing as anyone else
I just mentioned.
I find climate change to be a really interesting
discussion because it often shows how ones
thinking works in other areas as well.
Generally speaking, Democrats or those on
the Left see climate change as man made and
believe governmental action is the best, or
in some cases the only way, to reverse its
negative effects.
Republicans, or those on the right, generally
believe that something is happening to the
environment, though there is some debate as
to whether it is man made, and in either case,
believe that the private sector is better
left to deal with these issues.
Of course there are outliers on each side,
such as my former guest, an California Democratic
gubernatorial candidate Mike Shellenberger
who wants the private sector to be more involved
in solving climate change issues.
And of course, there are also Republicans
and people on the right who deny man made
climate change at all.
The science debate on climate change is an
interesting one, and one in which I'm happy
to have.
What interests me more though, is how government
should, or should not, be part of the solution
to whatever the problem may be.
You know my feelings on this, that the government
is rarely the solution to anything.
Actually, at this point, I think the government
is usually the problem in the first place,
and I'd always rather exhaust private options
before turning to the government, especially
the federal government.
Ironically, this should be the position of
the people who hate Trump, why would you want
to keep giving the government more power when
you hate the guy in charge, but at the end
of the day its not governmental power they
have a problem with, its that they only have
a problem with governmental power when its
not their guy in charge.
Fortunately, there seems to be a younger generation
that is tackling issues like climate change
and the environment in a totally new way.
It seems to be based not only in scientific
facts but also in an understanding of how
a limited government should work.
My guest this week is Benji Backer, President
of the American Conservation Coalition.
The group is dedicated to finding new ways
to look at old problems.
As its mantra states, they are committed to
efficient, effective, conservative environmentalism.
As for me, I am a believer in the science
behind climate change, and the funny thing
about science is that it doesn't care whether
you believe in it or not.
For me the, real debate around climate change
is how to go about finding solutions without
giving more power and money to government.
Whether you believe in climate science or
not, whether you want more government regulation
or less, or whether you believe the private
section can find solution or not, we're all
still stuck on this rock together.
So until Elon Musk, a private businessman
gets us all to Mars, let's try to figure out
how to solve some of our problems on this
pale blue dot while we still have the chance...